GUEST SPEAKER:
Governor, thank you
so much for asking me to outline
a comprehensive cost-benefit
analysis, regaring
decision making
over a long delayed clean up
of a highly polluted Superfund
site.
As we know, underground
storage tanks at the site
have leaked into nearby
wetlands and cleanup is expected
to cost $35 million or more.
The debate centers around
the city's eagerness
to reuse this site
for a new mall.
And who should be
held accountable
for the costs associated with
this clean up, as the state
government has no
funds, and the company
responsible for the damage has
since gone out of business,
leaving even no
clients remaining.
Including an alterior road that
would link to the Superfund
site to a nearby
highway would provide
additional accessibility,
and consequently
more business for the
mall, perhaps justifying
more government spending.
As you know, Governor,
multiple parties
are pressuring you
in this decision,
and there is no
consensus as to who
should bear the cost of
ensuring the site is safe
and of redeveloping the site.
You asked me to outline a
comprehensive cost-benefit
analysis that can be done to
help answer this question.
I would argue that a
cost-benefit analysis should
not in fact be used in this
decision-making process,
as I believe the method
is deeply flawed,
and may lead to
misleading results,
exacerbating feelings of
poorly distributed benefits
among parties.
While proponents of
cost-benefit analysis
assert that it, 1, results in
the more efficient allocation
of resources and, 2, provides
objectivity and transparency,
in a paper titled Pricing
the Priceless by Frank
Ackerman and Lisa
Heinzerling, the authors
argue against these
arguments by illuminating
four fundamental flaws
to cost-benefit analysis.
I will outline some of these
fundamental flaws in relation
to the case the Superfund
site and provide thoughts
for an alternative approach.
The first fundamental
flaw centers around it
cost-benefit
analysis, the process
of reducing life, health,
and the natural world
to monetary values.
For example, according
to cost-benefit analysis,
preventing the
extinction of bald eagles
is worth $250 per household.
And saving a human
life is calculated
to be worth $6.3 million.
For the people in this scenario
that we're talking about today,
a risk of toxic poisoning due to
the previous industrial factory
operations at the site,
the price of their health,
and even their lives, cannot
be assigned a finite amount
of money.
Furthermore, the
$6.3 million figure
is not considered by the
cost-benefit analysis
to be a price of life, but
the cost of the risk of death.
According to
Ackerman, in this way
the cost-benefit analysis
equates the risks
of death with death
itself, which are actually
two different calculations.
The second, cost-benefit
analysis ignores the reality
that citizens are
concerned about risks
to others and in addition
to their concern about risk
to themselves.
If we do a cost-benefit
analysis looking
at the rebuilding of
the Superfund site,
our analysis can't
quantify the value
to our townspeople
people of the lives
and health of their relatives,
and friends, and even
strangers in the town.
Thirdly, cost-benefit
analysis fails
to address the collective
choice presented
to society, as its valuation
of environmental benefits
is based only individual's
private decision as consumers,
and not collective
decisions as citizens.
For example, a
study by Mark Sagoff
found that his students
in their role as citizens
opposed commercial ski
development of a wilderness
area, but in their role
as consumers would plan
to ski there if it were actually
built. So in this scenario,
cost-benefit analysis could
take into account only
our towns peoples'
willingness to pay
for a new mall as
individuals and consumers,
and not how they value this
site and its environmental
and community value as citizens.
In addition, there
are fundamental flaws
and the use of discounting.
While discounting acknowledges
that individuals believe
it is better for them to suffer
harm later rather than sooner,
it doesn't address the
very, very long term,
where discounting its a
choice between preventing harm
to the current generation
and preventing similar harms
to future generations.
And discounting also assumes
that environmental problems
won't get any worse if
we wait to address them,
and that technology
will keep evolving
so that future solutions
will do more and cost less.
Therefore, if we do a
cost-benefit analysis
for the remediation of
this Superfund site,
we cannot take into account
the possibility that we find
an additional or irreversible
toxic pollution source that we
do not currently know exists.
Based on these fundamental
flaws in cost-benefit analysis
outlined by Ackerman
and Heizerling,
we cannot expect such an
analysis to be either objective
or transparent.
In fact, the
cost-benefit analysis
relies on a series of
assumptions and value
judgements that are
far from objective.
As a result, I don't
think we should
use a cost-benefit
analysis for our analysis.
But rather, I think
we should look
to past situations of
Superfund site remediation
that may add in our
understanding of how
other towns have addressed
such complex situations
and undertake economic analyzes
of various past planning
decisions that could
inform our own situation.
Another idea would
be to potentially--
based on public
town hall hearings--
move toward the
consideration of a local vote
to decide whether a tax can be
applied to the town's citizens
and collected into
a pool that will
go towards cleaning the site
and rebuilding the mall.
I look forward to continuing to
analyze alternative approaches
to evaluate our best
options going forward
in this complex situation.